stephen lawrence et 22 ans et pierre
chapin 33 ans décède dans cette terrible
fusillade de sainte anne en 2014 elle
s'est déroulée sur cette plage de la
pointe du marais au restaurant le
toulousain au cours d'une soirée privée
une altercation éclate le ton monte plus
de dialogue
seuls les détonations les armes à feu
vient troubler cette ambiance festive
bilan deux morts et six autres personnes
gravement blessées
à l'issue de nombreuses investigations
et auditions deux hommes sont placés en
détention provisoire
un troisième sous contrôle judiciaire
ils sont mis en examen pour meurtre
tentative de meurtre violences avec arme
cette audience de la cour d'assises de
martinique est prévue du 21 au 25
janvier
autre dossier des assises au les armes à
feu son centre des débats
le 26 avril 2014 armés jusqu'aux dents
trois ans d'origine sainte lucienne
sèment la terreur à cette marie ils
dépouillent plusieurs personnes étant de
prendre la fuite rapidement prise en
chasse par les gendarmes
l'un des fuyards ouvre le feu en
direction des militaires interpellés ils
sont condamnés à des peines de 15 à 10
ans de prison et ils refusent ce verdict
et il faut aussitôt appel dès lundi
matin sont à nouveau dans le box des
accusés
autre dossier en appel analysée par les
jurés de la cour d'assises dès mercredi
prochain
celui de normes condamné à 17 ans de
réclusion criminelle son procès est
prévu sur deux jours du 16 au 17 janvier
mais ces différentes audiences vont
elles se déroulaient correctement aux
faire l'objet de renvoi des avocats du
barreau de martinique
toujours mobilisés contre le projet de
réforme du gouvernement hôte pour une
autre forme de mobilisation
en revanche les magistrats risque de
répondre à l'appel du syndicat de la
magistrature à partir de mardi prochain